[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle journée nous sommes le mardi 21
mai et hélène 9 heures j'espère que vous
êtes au fort romain
en tout cas moi je suis ravi de vous
retrouver au programme aujourd'hui une
matinale rock des années 70
et cet après midi nous continuerons la
lecture du roman la nuit des temps de
barjavel et c'est l'heure d'entamer
notre matinale rock des seventies avec
le premier album deron wire qui a été au
début de cette décennie
le groupe qui a révolutionné le rock
anglais et ils viennent tout droit de
brighton merci papa pour sa découverte
ça c'était du rock
[Musique]
vous
nous allons maintenant faire un petit
point météo nous sommes donc au jour 782
il selon mes calculs une tempête de
force 4 devrait arriver entre 12h et
13h30 avec une première phase
d'impulsion assez violent qui devrait
durer une dizaine de minutes et une
deuxième phase qui devrait durer environ
trois heures surtout soyez très prudents
et n'oubliez pas d'éteindre complètement
vos appareils électriques avant la
première phase je répète une tempête de
force 4
dans deux à trois heures
prenez soin de vous et si vous
m'entendez contactez-moi sur les
fréquences 89 6 92 4 96 300
[Musique]
si quelqu'un m'entende je vous en
supplie contactez moi
[Musique]
oh
le
je
je sais quoi tu vas te débrouiller tout
seul but si tu fais plus j'ai très envie
de jouer
à
m
e
[Musique]
ici à l'iss je vais de retour avec vous
j'espère que tout le monde va bien j'ai
le regret de vous annoncer que
l'intervalle entre les tempêtes se
réduit à vue d'oeil
passant à moins de deux jours toujours
selon faire
je vais vous laisser en musique prenez
soin de vous
[Musique]
c'est le constat amer
hu jintao
watch the fame
[Musique]
watch sur la camp
bah
que parra que passe
parler d' imposteur et du monde
[Musique]
c
le bois et ses hommes
[Musique]
alors que passais le bac gris
alors que bas que paris allait
que par là de passer à la lie
[Musique]
c'est moi
ouais ok de base